I seek out experts and I've always done
that to learn any skill even when I
wanted to learn Facebook ads way back in
the day I went to a guy who was an
agency owner and I said hey I want to
learn how to run ads and so finally he
said 750 an hour and I was like cool all
right once a week we'll hop on 700 an
hour and you don't have to do anything
else I was like but I want to control
the computer and I'll do the clicking
and you tell me why I'm doing it and it
took me I think like eight hours with
him to like learn how to run Facebook
ads six grand made me millions and
millions and millions of dollars I'm a
big fan of 101 tutoring and most times
people are afraid to spend like the
money for the hour you'll learn as fast
as you can and just do the homework like
be a good student that is how I have
learned the vast majority of my things
is by other people and doing